So let's talk about three of the best ways to measure brain activity, starting
with the electroencephalography. This is commonly called an EEG. It records
electrical activity of the brain through electrodes placed on the scalp. This
technique is really good at showing general activity of the brain, but it's not
terribly precise at showing where exactly the activity is occurring. This is
what a typical one would look like. Next, we have the Positron Emission
Tomography or PET scan for short. This measures blood flow to brain areas that
are activated because neural response requires blood. This technology requires
a person to ingest a harmless radioactive form of oxygen or glucose. The
radioactive level in the oxygen is picked up by the scanning device during
brain activity. Computers then color code the most active areas in red,
somewhat active areas in yellow, and the least active areas in blue and green,
like you see here. And finally, we have the Functional Magnetic Resonance
Imaging, or FMRI for short. This also measures blood flow to active brain
regions. But it doesn't use radioactive forms of oxygen. Instead, the FMRI uses
magnetic fields to detect regions of the brain that are activated. One
advantage of this, is that it can give us a very precise picture of which part
of the brain is active. This is what a typical FMRI machine looks like. Now,
it's really important to point out that none of these techniques directly
measure neural activity. They all measure indirectly. There are ways of
measuring individual neurons, but because it involves surgery its almost never
used on humans. I know there's a lot of information on brain structure. So, if
you need to you can go over some of the parts of the lesson again or always go
back to the document we gave you.